foreign
I think this is a good question that a
lot of couples have and by a lot you
mean you and your husband go ahead how
many times a week should a couple have
sex
10 11. I'm just kidding
uh you're welcome gentlemen you're
welcome
[Music]
what's up this is John with the Dr John
deloney show the greatest mental health
and marriage and relationship and
parenting podcast show ever
so glad that you joined us if you want
to be on this show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 and here's my promise
I'll always tell you the truth even when
I don't know I'll tell you I don't know
and I'm not gonna talk at you I'm gonna
talk with you
just you and me sitting at a bar trying
to figure this out you and me having
some nachos
um sitting down sharing some chips and
queso saying all right what are we gonna
do next
uh here's what I would do next right so
if you want to be on the show give me a
call or go to John delaney.com ask
and um we'll figure out what to do next
let's go to Nikki in chai town in
Chicago what up Nikki
hi what's up
not much I'm excited to uh get to talk
to you and get your perspective on some
situations that I'm going with right now
very cool thanks for your trust I'm
grateful for you what's up thanks
um so I
I'm a little bit of uh animosity and
resentment towards my new husband's
ex-wife
and I was kind of hoping to get your uh
perspective on how to just cope with
that
wow okay
um tell me about it
so my husband and I have been together
for two years and married for two months
and between the two of us we have five
daughters
um so we are in a five daughters yeah
yeah
hey have your have your husband call the
show I just want to hug him
I just want to hug him yeah yeah he's
amazing actually uh he met you a few
years back uh during the entree
Leadership Summit so she wanted me to
tell his old friend John hi hello and he
didn't lead with hey there's six women
in my house
at least get him a boy dog or something
all right so we have a boy dog he
insists that the animals are male so
I support that man I support that all
right so yeah he's got an ex-wife I've
been married just a couple of months
tell me about it five daughters
yeah five daughters
um so a couple years ago when I came
into the situation
um him and his ex-wife were
uh co-parenting I I think a little too
well they they were still doing like
family things together and um
so when I came in I was like
yeah that's gonna change I don't
I'm not comfortable with like Christmas
at your ex-wife's house so things have
slowly kind of
why why are you uncomfortable with that
um
I'm not saying you shouldn't be I just
why
no I think
the issue for me was his co-parenting
situation was polar opposite of my
co-parenting situation
um my ex-husband's bipolar and it's it's
really hard to manage and I've I've been
on my own
even when we were married since the kids
were born I was basically a married
single mom and so coming from that
situation into his situation where they
still do like pumpkin patch picking
together and
but she's in a relationship and he's in
a relationship it was
it was just uncomfortable
so that that you landed there I'm so
glad you got there it sounds like they
have figured out a way to be divorced to
move on with their lives and still be
adults for their kids
possibly is still too weird
um that's that that would be a whole
other conversation with them too just to
listen to How they've arrived at where
they've arrived but the number of people
I talk to across the country who cannot
earn yours most people end up in your
situation I cannot get my spouse to do
my ex to do anything remotely like an
adult or they're struggling with mental
health issues or they just disappeared
or whatever
what is it are you jealous of her and
it's okay if you are just be honest are
you jealous of her are you jealous of
their former relationship or do you love
her him and you're like is that weird
gnawing feeling that he had a thing with
her once like what what is it there's
definitely uh jealousy okay underlying
there
um but where we're landed at today is
the relationship has dissolved and
there's no more co-parenting and it's
very her side our side and
um she's starting to be very childish
and being friends with the kids instead
of
being a team with us
and I think I I would assume on her part
that is because you know there are
issues there with me well you you broke
up their team you said you said this
team isn't can't play like this anymore
not with me in the picture
and so yeah the team she's gonna feel
like
he decided that their co-parenting
Arrangement was no good and he picked
you over her
yeah and so part of the jealousy issue
was because when we first met he told me
early on that two months before he met
me she was she wanted him back and he
had said no okay so then I was
increasing Memorial uncomfortable
you know doing anything so let's let's
clear this up they are linked forever
right and by marrying him
you have to deal with her
yeah and so you can fight that forever
or you can make peace in your soul and
here's the deal if he goes back to her
one day let's say that happened it's not
going to but let's say it did
your paranoia and frustration and
jealousy and anger and I don't like that
none of that will help that it will only
accelerate it
I think that's where we've landed is
the things that she has done from the
beginning are
wrong and offensive and I have every
right to be mad but where I'm coming
like what like what
um like when we first got together she
did a background check on me and
absolutely I would do the same thing I
would do the same thing
I want to know who's in the lives of my
kids absolutely
I don't think that's weird at all if she
hid it from you lied about it okay but
you have to understand you're like
you know what I mean would you trust
some strange woman with your kids like
you'd want to know right yes but I don't
think she like I don't think she needed
to share my debt like that was her
digging because she knows he's big into
Dave Ramsey and big on debt free that's
fine that's fine okay so she was she was
she handled that immaturely yeah but why
are you giving her a rent-free space in
your head
yeah that's what my husband gives up he
says like I don't understand how you
could be so
stuck on something that happened two
years ago and it's like well it's
because she's kind of like a trigger at
this point and no you're allowing her to
why why are you giving her this power
what is it about her is she beautiful is
she rich is she wonderful I think what
is it
when you when you hold her up you see
yourself as less than why
um I don't necessarily see myself as
less than I I just feel like
there's things in the situation that I
can't control yes
and you can't control her deciding to be
friends with her kids
now and I can't control her like
teaching the kid like we're to a point
where the children see every single
thing their mom does is correct and
every single thing their dad does is
wrong great yeah that's a season and
that will shift and then one day it will
be everything dad does is the best ever
and you're their best friend and Mom's
the worst
like it's not a competition at this
point
we're trying to raise well kids
who have grown up in trauma
and
have a very confusing childhood between
whatever
one two three years led to a divorce and
then this weird we're still kind of a
family but not really and then mom's
with somebody else and then oh something
dads with somebody else like that's
trauma for kids
right and so if they connect with a
parent that's normal they're going to do
that trying to fight that or be
frustrated by that
is you comparing yourself why don't they
like me as much as her or why don't they
like us is our rules are but man that's
just that's just throwing angst into an
already angsty situation situation can't
control it if she's abusing them or if
she's
um not following the court orders or she
is making putting them in situations
where they're not safe yeah man I'm all
in on that
uh but if she just feeds a McDonald's
every time it's frustrating and
maddening and there's going to be a
re-entry point every time they come back
to your house
right or like Mom doesn't make us two
that I know but I do
yeah it's not necessarily that bad it's
it's things that we can't control like
like her sense of humor with them in my
opinion is abusive like she calls them a
failure and thinks that's funny
and you know if they don't perform well
at soccer she's like the mom that's the
loudest one they are going you're not
getting any dinner tonight and it's just
like they know they missed the goals
they
know these things what can you do about
that
nothing that's that's so where my
struggle is you can keep holding Tighter
and Tighter or you can let go
how
you gotta practice that and number the
first thing you got to practice it but
before that actually that's the second
thing the first thing is you have to
decide to let go
and my guess is grow uh being in love
with somebody and being connected to
somebody and making kids is somebody who
had bipolar disorder meant you had to
drive everywhere for everything because
you couldn't depend on anybody but
yourself
and you were every bit his mother as you
were his lover and that probably started
way back when you were a little kid
and the control that kept you alive in
that relationship and the control that
you had to exert over your life when you
were a kid
is what's choking the life out of your
current marriage
is that fair
yeah
so it's what we're doing is we have to
say okay
um Justin Verlander was pitching and he
throws a million miles an hour
so I'm going to have to swing really
fast I don't have to make up my decision
quick as he goes into his wind-up and
then another pitcher is going to come up
there and throw a bunch of curveballs
Greg Maddox is going to come up and
pitch and he throws very slow but he
throws all like all this curved stuff so
I gotta be a little more patient it's a
different I gotta approach this thing
differently
and right now control for you giving
that up letting go with that
um feels like you're gonna you're
exposing yourself to more hurt is that
fair
yeah
and what I want you just to step back
and look at the pictures it's the
control right now that's killing you
or
I'm a seven and my husband's a one yeah
yeah so he doesn't get it nope your
childhood sucked didn't it
I'm sorry
he can't get it unless you talk to him
about it have you talked to him about it
yeah a lot okay yeah okay he's great
so here's your practice
over time
it's feeling your body start to try to
grab control of situations that you
can't control
and holding your breath for about four
or five seconds as deep as you can
and exhaling and intentionally dropping
your shoulders pulling them down and
opening your hands up say I can't
control this one
and this hurts
here's what I can control and we're
going to go that route and what we're
going to do is just practice this
is that something you're interested in I
don't think you believe that you're
worth a peaceful life
um it's not that I don't believe it it's
just that
I shouldn't experienced it
so like when my husband and I first got
together I and we would have conflict I
would like feel my body tensing and like
my fist in the air almost like
metaphorically because I Was preparing
for that fight yeah and whoever came so
I've slowly like
I don't have those kind of conflicts
with him we really never fight when we
do it is always about his ex-wife I I
would suggest Nikki you're always at War
always
he might not know he's fighting you do
there's an Asus score of one is going to
go through life pretty go lucky
yeah and uh well that stinks let's do
this
yeah I don't know if you're familiar
with like
Enneagram personalities
um he's a nine he's a peacekeeper and
I'm an eight I'm a fighter
[Music]
it's always so amazing how y'all find
each other it's so good so he has this
like uncanny ability to like let things
roll off his back and I like keep score
well you had to okay you had to
um
one other thing I I have argued with
some of the great leaders in the
Enneagram world I I don't believe that
those things are innate that we're just
wired for that I think there's a
combination of wiring and and experience
you've had to fight
because if you don't fight with an Aces
score of a seven you and I aren't
talking
right
you're you're strung out somewhere or
you're you're in jail or you're in a
you're dead right right you've had to
fight
you haven't been able to recognize that
the fighting that kept you alive is
blowing things up right now
here here's the the way through it and
for somebody with an Aces score of seven
if you haven't had trauma counseling
you're probably gonna need it
um I recommend anybody over a four go do
that
um but
the only way through it
I mean the only way to heal is to go
directly through it
that's the only path forward you want to
do something crazy call his ex-wife and
say you want to go to breakfast
I've suggested that so and that was
actually one of our arguments because
early on I was like why don't we just go
to dinner and like have a sit down and
kind of map this thing out with the four
adults you know in the room and he was
like no no no no and then his ex-wife
suggested it and he's like I think we
should do this
okay hold on hold on
[Laughter]
oh geez
so the way you just said that clearly he
listens to her more than you he's still
in love with her more than you I can't
I'm just I'm just B Team
and the way I hear that is
when you suggested it he was like oh
honey I'm not taking you to War I don't
want to fight and then when she said she
was into it she he was like okay maybe
this would work out
but exactly what he said I hear that as
a husband trying to protect his new wife
who's a little bit um one Anarchist
um and realizing that we could we could
probably make this thing happen I don't
think he should go with him the first
time
I think you should go just YouTube
grown women and you start the whole
conversation with I have completely
screwed this up
try there and I get it the silence is
deafening right now it's so good because
you're like to hell with that I ain't
saying that to that crazy listen if you
walked in and said I screwed this up I'm
jealous of your marriage I come from
abuse I was married to someone with
bipolar so I've just been in chaotic
relationships and I just started trying
to control everything
and I recognize I love him and I love
those girls and by loving him and loving
those girls that means I'm going to be a
part of your life forever
and so I want to I want to restart
if you went in with that attitude she
would probably have to pick her jaw up
off the floor
and you pay for you pay for the meal
and you also by the way have your
shoulders down the whole time you're
just like consciously pulling them down
and you're just kind
the word for that is the the brene brown
special it's vulnerable she could roast
you she could burn a hole through you
with that sort of vulnerability
she could or
y'all could get to some relational
ground that y'all are never going to get
to unless one of you acts like an adult
and just takes a knee
and yeah that's kind of where I'm
struggling is because why what what has
worked over the last two years
nothing it's just getting worse
isn't it it is it is it is so stop
fighting it's not that's clearly not
working
it's not working if you were a doctor
you would have fired yourself
because this medicine isn't working
would you just try it and see what
happens
yeah oh yeah I definitely want
more than anything to just have like
inner peace and stop being at conflict
with the whole situation you were gonna
have that's you've got to get a
counselor here's why your body is gonna
have to practice peace because it's
never had it
it's it's a unicorn right now it's like
a mythological place you've never
experienced it
and you want it but you don't even know
what it is you don't even know what it
feels like and you're gonna have to
practice it and you're gonna have to get
somebody to walk with you and when those
girls when did your abuse start
even as a child or with my marriage as a
child
it's just it's never been
from day one like it's never been great
okay you've you're surrounded by five
girls
your body's alarm systems are going to
ring off the freaking hook right
yeah because it remembers that story of
what happens when you're a little girl
so your job as the adult as the parent
of five little girls
is to go do the work to heal those
alarms and redirect them
because you don't want to pass that
trauma to them
you want them to be aware and smart and
bright and able to read a room and able
to keep themselves safe all those things
are good
but you can't do those things when your
body's under threat because it just says
get out of here
right and I don't want them to feel like
they have to choose that's right
so that that healing isn't something you
you tell them
it's something you do for you and they
absorb it they feel it
right is that fair yeah the only thing
in this whole situation you can you the
only person you can change is you that's
it
and it's just asking yourself is this
working and you and I both it's not it's
not
no it's not
and so I'm just suggesting try something
completely different if you take her to
breakfast and it goes it just goes off
the rails
just off the rails
um
you'll have learned something right
right you can say I tried that that
didn't work that was that was not good I
called some podcaster and he's an idiot
oh hey I will announce to everyone who
listens uh Nikki called me back and said
um she went on that breakfast and
her
husband's ex was it just ruined
everything like it was a disaster I I
will I'll put that out to the world
that's fair I don't think that will
happen
maybe it will but I don't think it will
and I'm not saying y'all gonna be best
friends you're not you're not gonna be
best friends you're not gonna call each
other and be like do you want to go get
pedicures it's not gonna happen
I'm not gonna go hang out at TJ Maxx do
people shop Kelly TJ I don't know
no Kelly's more of a Carhartt gal what
I don't know where people go shopping
I'm just saying you're not going to be
shopping partners
but you are gonna have to learn how to
do life together you're gonna have to
figure this out and
it's just being an adult it's putting
away the immediate putting away the hard
stuff for the things that are right the
things that are best long term
um hang on the line here Nikki I'm gonna
send you a copy of my book I want you to
read it from start to finish it's about
dealing with trauma it's a call in your
past change your future hang on the line
here I'm gonna send you a free copy
um please reach out to a counselor in
your community and say I'm ready
kind of rough go of it I've got a
marriage worth hanging on to now
um I've met a guy that's good I've got
five kids that I'm wrestling with I've
got a
um a blended family that I'm I've now
entered into I don't want to do this
right and I deserve to be well I deserve
peace I deserve
oh I'm gonna start there thank you for
being brave Nikki I'm grateful for you
let me know how that that breakfast goes
we'll be right back
for John deloney here can we all just
take a minute to take a deep breath
ah there's a lot going on in our homes
our neighborhoods and across the world
and it might be stressing you out I know
I'm more stressed than usual but
remember we've been through Seasons like
this before and the best thing we can do
is to focus on controlling what we can
control
you can control your spending your
saving how much time you're spending on
electronics you can control your daily
habits and you can control making time
for sleep this one is easy to forget
especially when you're stressed but
sleep is key to taking care of your
physical and mental health and I have
found the key to great sleep is a great
mattress and that's why I love dream
Club mattresses they're so comfortable
and right now dream cloud is making it
easy to invest in good sleep with a
great deal 599 dollars in accessories
plus an additional 250 discount that's a
total of 849 dollars in accessories and
savings go to dreamcloudsleep.com
deloney or dreamcloudsleep.com and enter
promo code deloni to get your new
mattress today
all right we're back let's go to Mark in
Savannah Georgia what's up Mark
hey Dr John party and how are you I'm
part of you do good good to hear it man
what's up well hey uh so a couple months
ago you had an episode where a woman
called in and she and her husband had
bought a farm and we're in the process
of fixing it or just trying to make the
farm life work and I actually listened
to that as we were doing some work on
our farm to close on it because we were
in the same boat
um and kind of working on escaping from
it
um and we're out of that now we're in a
new whole situation new life which is
much better
um I I guess I just kind of wondering
how to move forward and kind of fix some
of the issues that came up from all that
uh everything we went through within
that what issues came up
so the the kind of situation was we
bought this old rundown Farm the house
needs fixed up the whole property needed
a lot of work so it was just a lot of
time and energy going into that okay
hold on that means before that
did y'all have a dream
yeah and then so it's been our Dream for
a long time to to have a farm and raise
our kids with animals and and have it be
you know a peaceful the the quiet Farm
life that we kind of
have you ever been on a farm
in Sex and poop that's basically a farm
yeah
that's a good point that's a good point
but yeah that was our Dream going into
it okay how long have you been married
uh 10 years okay so that's a long time
of watching HGTV videos and YouTube
videos and like going through Zillow
over and over again like right
yeah yes okay so you got this Farm
you're gonna Fix It Up You're Gonna
Learn you can just YouTube everything
and it just it's a nightmare right
yeah
[Laughter]
Hey listen here's why I'm laughing at
work before but here's what I'm like I
live on a similar situation and my wife
grew up that way and so I had the luxury
of being like here's what we're gonna do
and she's like you're an idiot that's
not how that's gonna work at all and uh
anyway I was just on the phone with the
guy just before this call I was on the
phone uh before the show started with
the guys who came out to service my well
and something in our spring I literally
have no idea what they're talking about
but I nodded and I was like yeah that
sounds great so good good for you okay
so disaster you'll have this dream y'all
think about it you plan together you you
dream together it's just gonna be this
Blissful thing where animals just
peacefully die so you can eat them and
crops just grow themselves and it always
rains okay so here you are
then what
so yeah we got into it we started doing
the house which I I had some background
doing that work as well so I wasn't
quite as as naive I guess maybe he may
not to be well it's not that if people
know people know how to hang drywall and
fix joists they don't know how to do
that and be married at the same time
sure that's the name so on and on top of
that I was starting a new marketing
company which is my
why not why why wouldn't we do that that
sounds fantastic excellent good job and
we have three kids that are under seven
absolutely why not oh it was just it was
just everything piling on you know as as
you're uh pointing out there and I I as
you can imagine you know we got to the
point where we were just gonna implode
if we didn't change something and and we
kind of powered through all of it
obviously it was stressful basically
from day one and we kind of powered
through
um I find myself I found myself kind of
having the dynamic of I'm gonna be the
strong one and put on a bold face and
not you know show that I'm struggling
with this and my wife was kind of the
opposite and struggling a lot through it
all and going along with it just uh
kind of make me happy or may try and you
know make the dream continue to work and
whatnot
um but it was slowly just go into a
really bad place and we finally got to
that Breaking Point instead
and it's kind of more heard telling me
you know I can't continue this or I have
to get out of the situation because
everything feels so unhealthy that
we got to get away from it so good for
her we finally did and and yeah you know
we feel so much better being away from
it but it's just we going through all
that put us in such a weird place and I
feel like now we we're almost we know
that there was some trauma and a lot of
hurt from that
it's just hard to identify what it even
is or talk about it I feel like a lot of
times it's hard for us to even just talk
and we'll just watch something or look
at our phones to kind of sure build the
silence it's hard to even know you know
where to begin thinking through all this
stuff as well so did anything happen
that caused a rift did you cheat on her
or no did she did you say something to
her did she hit you I mean is there
anything like of that nature that
there's these unspoken elephants in the
room that we got to address
foreign
no not an unspoken thing the only thing
is you know she got to the point where
she said if we you know I was kind of
continuing to try and build my my new
business and make the dream work like I
said I was kind of putting on the brave
face and she was more than one kind of
saying this isn't working and she got to
the point where she said
you know if if you're gonna keep
pursuing this I have to leave and I will
divorce you okay and that's and that was
kind of like that really was the
breaking point for me to think okay it's
either the dream or my marriage and I'm
you know halfway going to choose my
marriage so all right hold on are you
are you are you happy about that choice
yes 100 okay when a guy tells me he's
putting on a brave face
What I Hear in my mind is I'm leaving my
wife
I am unplugging from her
and I am surrounding myself in a in a
sheet of iron so that I can just plow
ahead
and when I do that she is unplugged
she's untethered I've left her
I might sleep in her same bed I might
eat at her same table but I have left
her in pursuit of and so what she was
identifying was you've left me I'm just
gonna make it for you
is that fair
and absolutely most of the time I don't
think guys want to do that I think y'all
y'all got in a dance right I've got to
keep this thing going she's like I got
to keep this thing going and both of
y'all were waiting for the other person
to say I'm out right and so she was just
gonna formalize it
often so here's a couple of things when
you think of trauma you failed at a
thing
and that's okay have you ever failed at
anything before did you ever get an F in
school or get fired from a job
yeah a few times okay so this is uh uh
my boss Dave says
um all success is built on a pile of
failures
and so it's setting back and saying okay
we had this dream we were and it's the
death of a Dream It's the death of a
picture of who y'all were gonna be right
yeah and so you have to acknowledge you
gotta grieve it here's what we wanted
and that's not gonna happen
and until you do that
most people skip that step and then go
okay well then we're gonna live a
Suburban life and do this and you're
gonna find yourself with two 2024 Tahoes
that you can't afford in a big house you
can't afford and you're going to be
trying to start another business and
right you can be running and chasing
instead of saying
we both really wanted this life and it
wasn't what we thought it was cracked up
to be and we both realized we don't talk
as well as we thought and we both
realized and she gets to say here's what
she realized
here's what she learned about her
husband
and you get to say here's what I learned
about my wife
and here's our new reality we got to own
that and then we get to decide what is
it going to look like next and you're
going to be tenuous to I mean it's going
to feel awkward to build a new dream
because y'all built one and it imploded
on it yeah is that fair
yeah yeah and so here's a here's another
thing
um
you've probably heard me talk about
pictures and words a lot the reason I
think reading is so powerful and my wife
is uh was a was a literacy scholar the
reason I think reading is so important
because it allows every reader to read
something
and they concoct the picture in their
mind and when we watch something on TV
it says it looks like that it gives the
spoon feeds us the picture here's where
that's important
you said we wanted this peaceful life
where we were all together and you
started creating sentiment behind a
picture but HGTV told you what that had
to look like
sure and instead of that I would rather
you go back to the values the principles
the feelings that you thought you were
going to get by this having this life
and try to build that wherever you are
so we want a peaceful life we want an
off-grid life we want a
um an accomplished life where we do
things together you see what I see what
I'm getting at you could do that in a
three-bedroom two-bath house in the
middle of some Rando suburb sure you can
get off the grid and get solar panels
and turn your backyard and your front
yard into my friend Pete did that he
just plowed up his whole front yard and
planted food there my friend Alex did
that in his backyard it's just awesome
so you can create that life wherever you
are but HGTV doesn't the one responsible
for what that ends up looking like you
and your wife are
right does that make sense and so it's
going back and saying okay how do we
rebuild this thing let's start with what
we want this to feel like and look like
and let's go from there sure yeah I know
that that totally makes sense I think
that's something we've kind of started
looking at And discussing and yeah
trying to figure out what's at the core
behind why we wanted that and how can we
achieve that so I think that definitely
makes sense where can I be super honest
with you
yeah I feel like you're not telling me
something
what is it she's she she almost walked
out why what was at the core of that
I think you hit it when you talked about
what it means to put on a brave face
with the kind of main issue that came up
that she's just saying I need more
communication okay and and yeah I wasn't
you know I wasn't communicating with her
because a lot of what I would tell her
is hey this one project didn't go as
smooth as I hoped it would or this is
going to cost more money or this is
worse than we thought it was
um did you hear did you hear how that
translates to my husband's lying to me
yeah
see what I'm saying
yeah and that that un untethers
relationships when somebody I mean
there's a few things that make somebody
feel unsafe when they know somebody's
Cuban secret trauma
right because we usually don't keep
secrets of great stuff going on
yeah have you sat down and said I wasn't
honest with you and I'm sorry and I'm
healing from that I tried to hide stuff
from you and I shouldn't have done that
have y'all had that conversation
not I mean not directly you know some of
that stuff came to head and then I kind
of say oh well here's what you know
here's how this actually what I didn't
quite tell you all of it necessarily and
and we kind of talked to you know that I
told you the reason I did it was a try
and you know save you the stress of
having to worry about it but I I maybe
we haven't necessarily claimed it as
what it was well that's that I mean
again I want you to hear that how she
hears it
um I'm the grown-up here and you're the
child I'm going to protect you from it
you don't worry your pretty little head
and she's probably pretty smart right
yeah oh yeah and she probably considered
herself an equal so here's where all
this heads
I would love for you to sit down
and write an honest letter to her
we are now how how long has it been
since you moved
uh three months now I think okay so we
are three months out 90 days ago we
finally got out of a mess
and we dreamed about this mess
and we dreamed about this life that we
were gonna have and now that particular
dream is over period
here's what I realized I did over that
time trying to keep that dream alive I
didn't tell you the truth
I left you I was absent I got more
focused on trying to save the business
than I did trying to connect with my
wife and my kids and and of all the
things
all right
and then I want y'all to go out and I
want you to read that to her
and the end of that letter is something
along the lines of I'm ready to start
building something new when you're ready
because you don't want her to feel
pressure to get up and start creating a
new thing
when she's still wrestling with the last
time I created something I was told I
was a child and I was left in the dark
and almost lost everything
that makes sense
yeah that does it's that magic I just
just we talked about the last call this
is vulnerability this is you saying I'm
sorry
and I'm ready to get back in the game
when you are and not pressuring her or
this I mean you're all in a good
situation right now job wise home-wise
all that yeah we are yeah absolutely
much better okay there's not a rush
and it is six months a year of just kind
of being and then discovering what comes
next
yeah can you wait that long
I think so I think we kind of got burned
out on
going for it as hard as we did so we're
kind of we're kind of a point where yeah
the relaxing and and taking it easy
sounds good for a little while and
here's here's um
I'm trying to think of
so this will happen again
one or both of you will fail at
something in the future
we're not trying to live a failure-free
life that's not a goal that's not
something I'm going I mean I want to
minimize failure I want to be smart
about it but it's going to happen I'm
going to do all some baseball I mean
some football coaches call the exact
right play the right statistically
speaking the right the the momentum
everything's right and it just doesn't
work the play doesn't work the guy falls
down that somebody doesn't guard this
right whatever happens
you're gonna fail the goal is okay
what can we do different next time so
that we don't get caught in this dance
that we end up way in debt we end up way
in a hole we end up having to lie to
each other and one of you ends up saying
I'm out
so here's an example I'm going to be
very uh 30 000 feet here because I want
to honor my I don't want to just air my
dirty laundry out but
um my wife and I went to dinner the
other night and what normally would have
been a three or four month three or four
months
of me like doing the silent treatment of
me like and then her responding to the
silent treatment with going very
introspective trying to do we went to
dinner in like in 45 minutes we figured
it out
because I stopped it way up I said hey
here's how I'm feeling right now and I'm
being vulnerable putting this out on the
table and it makes me feel awkward and
weird because I'm a grown man from Texas
I don't like talking about this stuff
but here's how I feel right now and she
said oh gosh hey I'm sorry you feel like
that way b i 100 get where you're coming
from
and now let's figure out what we do next
and it literally was 45 minutes so yeah
that's not the issues the issues were a
big deal they were a big deal
it was the it was the strategy and the
skill set heading into that that just
made it a pretty relatively uh um
it's gonna sound super weird it was an
intimacy forming conversation
it's one of those that you got done with
it we're like I was I'm glad we did that
I had that conversation yeah now I feel
even better about our relationship
instead of it being a three month ordeal
enough oh she's gonna leave me all that
stupid stuff see what I'm saying yeah so
what are the skills y'all can walk away
with I think that's where we're heading
into this thing and maybe you when you
in this letter you tell her I'm gonna
commit from this point forward I will
never keep a secret from you again
I will always commit to telling you when
things are great and I will commit to
telling you when things are tough
I'll also commit to listening
and I'll always commit to keeping you
informed here's what it's going to look
like I would propose once a week we're
gonna have a budget meeting and a
calendar meeting and a check-in how are
you doing how are things going
and ask her what would be a good gift to
you in this season and by the way those
gifts will change the seasons will
change but right now
what is what's the best way we could
plug back in
and let her speak into it and commit not
to doing your own thing to fix it but to
listening to her and helping meet her
needs as y'all figure this thing out
moving forward
um
congratulations I'm proud of you man
y'all went for it you got in the ring
and you saw the biggest dude there and
you swung as hard as you could you just
he just hit you back right and that
happens that's life I've got a oh man
I've got a trail of failures in my life
um
that's part of it it's part of it
and you got a wife that's smart enough
and loves you enough to say to Turn All
the Lights On turn the music off and say
what are we doing because I'm about to
leave this party
if you were lucky married well my friend
um now it's just a fun question of what
do we do now
can't wait to hear what y'all do we'll
be right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from our sponsor from betterhelp I've
been on the giving and receiving end of
therapy for years when I was spitting
out like a decade ago with wild anxiety
I had a moment that light bulb moment
that I knew I had to do something
different I knew I had to change
something probably a lot of some things
right but I found myself without the
tools for taking the next step
and when you're facing problems or
challenges in life it's way too easy to
get stuck in that anxious spiral of Doom
I've been there but when you learn how
to stop that cycle and start taking
ownership of your life that's when
you're free and that's what therapy can
help you do it gives you the tools you
need to do the problem solving in your
own life and that's why I love better
help better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist it's more
affordable than in-person therapy plus
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours if you're ready to get
the tools that you need to deal with the
curveballs life's thrown at you therapy
can help visit betterhelp.com deloni to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com deloney
all right we are back and uh it's time
for drum roll please uh lightning round
another
look at that way to go way to go Ben
with the jamming Tunes uh it's lightning
round y'all loved it the last time we
did it so we're doing it again as a
reminder Kelly Cuts me off to get a
minute
roughly roughly until Kelly gets tired
of listening to me and I have no idea
zero I've got no idea what these
questions are where they're coming from
who's asking Jenna or Kelly me okay and
they're about what these are all about
relationships thematically yes
are you going to ask me about what
happens when a producer takes over a
show and they're just mean you can ask
me that question no I know how that
relationship ends yeah I don't know how
to I don't know how to handle that I
wouldn't be good these are all pretty
much about marital relationships marital
dating that kind of thing okay you got
it that's all I'm giving you and I wish
y'all could see she's got a smile on her
face because she knows she's gonna lob
grenades in here and I can't do anything
about it and I only get a minute and I
talk too long anyway okay let's do this
I'm ready
all right question one what advice would
you give to a young single male looking
for a relationship make yourself the
best version of you you can be
quit trying to figure out find other
people to make you feel good about
yourself go exercise go get a great job
go get a couple of mentors go do big
things go out swing and go join an MMA
gym go do stuff go join a violin class
or a guitar class or a salsa dancing a
knitting I don't care what you do go
make yourself the best version of you
you can be so that when you run into
somebody they don't look at you as a
project they look at you as a yes please
look at you 30 seconds left really yeah
that's the first so proud of you ever
ever all right next question is that a
good answer what do you think about that
actually I think that was fantastic
worry about you not about getting in the
relationship I think that's a fantastic
answer
all right what do you do when one spouse
is ready to have kids or adopt and the
other isn't
leave them
divorce probably
I'm just the only way that's the only
way and that's the last time we did no
don't do that okay what's the question
again
what do you do when one spouse is ready
to leave or to have kids or adopt and
the other one isn't
I think
the decision to have kids or not have
kids is one of the core challenges
um that all relationship all marriage
relationships face and I think it's
getting to the core of that
um underneath it I'm put on Earth to be
a mom I really want to be a dad
um my life isn't full without what is
what are you afraid of I think getting
to those things and really being very
very specific what are the core fears
one of each one of you who doesn't want
to have kids what are the core fears
what are the core Pros like here's what
I really want to have children and
getting to the core of that stuff and
then at some point and it sounds awful
you got to negotiate let's I need six
months and let's figure it out all right
the timers all right
how do you the next question how do you
fight fair in relationships
here's my rule for fighting
um you don't fight when you're mad
and you don't fight in the heat of
you have
I don't even honestly I'm gonna be I
don't like the word fighting
um there's passionate disagreements I'm
just fighting I fight when I'm trying to
protect somebody
um I fight when with the intention of
hurting somebody and that's not how you
engage in relationship disagreements so
my rule is I don't fight when I'm mad I
don't disagree when I'm mad I walk away
I literally walk away sometimes it's for
30 minutes sometimes it's for 30 days
I'm not ready to have this conversation
yet I will come back and I'll be plugged
in
um and then when I come back in I'm very
specific I don't use words like
um
oh I'm very eye-centric I feel I'm
experiencing not you did and it's all
about here's what I'm bringing to the
table and then I ask my wife to bring
that back is that fair that's great okay
awesome you fight when you're mad
I'm learning not to really yeah way to
go because I'm I'm
as my husband lovingly calls me a bit of
a bulldozer I've never experienced that
yeah and so I just lied to America but
he needs to walk away and I usually am
you know Chase right after him but I am
learning to let him walk away we'll talk
think about it and then come back and
it's always more productive okay can I
ask you this question sure I have heard
it said that when somebody has the
maturity to walk away sometimes they say
this isn't a good conversation
that that in and of itself is like
dumping gasoline on a fire like oh
you're Mr mature and it just makes it
worse it can be definitely if if in my
case where I'm like oh okay well you
don't want to talk about this you know
blah blah but it
to me that was clear that I needed to do
more work than on me because
that person probably and you know later
you're like yeah that was the mature
choice so it was no I need to back up
I'm willing to be wrong here I don't I I
just don't have an experience in my life
we're fighting with somebody I love
solved anything no no it doesn't because
things you don't want to say come out
and yeah yeah you know accusations and
this that and the other so it never
works yeah
we'll leave it at that all right cool
this is not for me this is somebody else
but I'm just going to read the question
sure 100 from tell me about your
marriage Kelly no my dad cheated on my
mom multiple times and now I'm married
I'm afraid my husband will cheat on me
can you Chief cheat proof a marriage
hmm can you cheat proof of marriage I
don't know that that's the goal
um
the goal is to love deeply if you play a
game to not lose you're going to play
timid you're going to
um
uh you're going to be constricted I want
to play the game to win so
um number one her body is going to to
think he's gonna cheat and that's okay
what she's got to do is is be open about
that and be honest about it and say
hitting this season when I'm learning
how to trust and not just learning
intellectually but learning like my body
learning how to trust you
um here's what I need and he's got to
understand where she came from where her
what the the world she comes from and
say okay I love you enough that I'm
gonna I'm gonna go a little bit further
than it makes sense even you can look at
my texts you can check out my Netflix
account here I'm a wide open book I'm
going to be a part of teaching her body
that she's safe and end man have a
regular check-in take care of yourselves
take care of each other and make it your
life's mission to meet the other
person's needs and if they make it their
life mission man it's really tough
you're done to go find love somewhere
else you don't need to all right you're
near
what's that sound oh I gotta tell you
that near story is pretty funny okay
it's not for today but it's awesome
how do you keep DIY home projects from
taking over your marriage
these don't ever do them don't do them
just stop
you know how many unfinished projects
here at my house 158
they're everywhere they're the worst a
don't don't B if you're going to have a
clear budget a clear I'm starting this
I'm going to finish it win a timeline
have enough people that can help you get
this thing started and finish it and you
cannot start any new project until this
one's finished period end of story and
this is the pot talking to the kettle
this is the single most hypocritical
thing I've ever said on the show don't
start anything until it's the other
thing's finished and if you're like but
I gotta do this cool sucks to be you you
got to finish the other thing first
that's just the way that's got to be and
you can't pull up all the hardwood
floors and be like I think I'm gonna
build a garden and then get halfway
through the garden and be like you know
what I need a pool and just start
shoveling in the backyard you can't do
it can't do it
that may be my favorite thing you've
ever said because you just
discussed my husband you just yeah if
you haven't got this by the way America
this is just like Kelly asked questions
about her marriage
the amount of Unfinished projects
anywho does he consider you an
unfinished project probably he's working
he's working hard I don't know if it's
going
in so how do you know when a
relationship is worth fighting for uh
[Music]
um
you make the choice
to keep fighting for it
um when two when you you and the other
person are both all in if one person is
partly in and the other person's all in
it's not gonna work
um when you are doing things because you
need this you're codependent
um when somebody is an addict and they
are trying to keep themselves alive over
here with unhealthy behaviors and you're
tagging along it's not gonna work so
it's worth fighting for when both of you
say and not just say but both do
I'm I'm all in I gotta learn new stuff
and it's gonna take a long time I gotta
learn how to trust again I gotta learn
how to fill in the blank I got to learn
how to handle money I gotta learn how to
not lie I gotta learn how to not drink
when I get upset or not overeat when I
get upset I gotta learn new things
but I promise I'm all in if you are
awesome all right next question
how do you maintain intimacy when you
have small kids at home
you don't you don't if you have two kids
five and under
it's a sex-free zone for a long time
just kidding it's not
um here's how you uh number one
you have to do the seemingly unsexy
thing but it's absolutely not is you
have to plan intimacy and intimacy by
the way isn't just doing it intimacy is
also we're just I want you to sit by me
and hold me while we watch a show I want
to hold hands under the covers and fall
asleep together while we're watching the
office
um intimacy is I just want to sit on the
front porch and have coffee together
intimacy might be
bananas wild sex with all your weird
fantasy that's fine let's figure this
thing out I'll get off the rails tonight
like whatever that looks like but here's
the key you gotta be intentional about
it you gotta map it out and you have to
talk and so guys if you're like I lost
my wife shut up you're fine but speak
out loud and ladies if women if you're
like intimacy means something different
to me in this season
um I don't like all these people pawing
all over whatever that great speak it
out loud and then be very clear about
what comes next
awesome all right my husband has been
hinting that he might like to go to
therapy should I encourage him yes
yes
um I will tell you my wife has quote
unquote encouraged me
um there's been a couple of times in our
20-year marriage and she reached out to
my friends and said John's not okay and
these aren't just buddies that I work
with these are guys that are
um as close as brothers
um and so she's reached out to a few
guys in my life over the years and
they've reached out and said hey you're
not doing all right what do you what do
you what actions are you going to take
and um they've been strongly encouraging
now right now we're I'm gonna season in
my marriage when my wife actually she
told me the other day I think you need
to call that guy and she's right I need
to call that guy so
um now we're in a season where she just
encourages me and I can hear it there
was Seasons when I couldn't hear it if
she had told me to go to counseling I
would have blown up and been like you
need to go to counseling you're the
crazy person and so it just yes
absolutely should encourage him but
encourage him in a way that he can hear
it not in a way that makes you feel
better or feel like I said so that's not
that's not helpful
awesome
um I am
I have not been invited or included by
the wives of my husband's friend group
how do I handle that
I don't know are you weird
and this is a question to you Kelly
because then you just asked that
question
um here's how you handle it um you got
rejected or you're getting rejected
you're in the act of getting rejection
one of the hardest things for married
couples especially newly married couples
is the expectation that you're just
going to be friends with their friend's
spouse
and that works for a season for a short
season occasionally you get to be pretty
tight but most of the time you have to
over time develop couple friends new
people that you hang out with and do
life with so if you realize that your
husband has some guy friends and their
wives are all buddy buddy and they don't
like you that stinks it hurts it's a
knife in your soul and more importantly
it's a knife in the picture of we're
just going to keep this party going we
are in college together and then we all
get married and now we're gonna have
kids together all gonna play Little
League together
they're not I know I'm still talking
they're not going to do that you're
gonna have to create new
um Community new friends so you're gonna
have to be honest with your husband and
he's gonna be like no it's not true I
don't they like you they just you have
to be honest about it and you've got to
do the hard work of finding other couple
friends and going out with them
man that stinks and it's not fun it's
the worst thing in the world is being an
adult making friends especially a couple
friends God help us but they are out
there and it's awesome just take some
work
add to that of course
um also because I have my group of
girlfriends and then
most of the husbands are friends as well
because we all met working in the same
industry and my husband is not a very
social person he's more of an introvert
and so he has expressed that same thing
at times and I said well the first few
times they asked you to do anything you
didn't so they quit asking
so at some point you may have to reach
out and say hey you want to go grab
coffee or so you may have to reach out
individually or with a couple of them
also that's a good point it may be
instead of doing like a couples thing
you reach out and ask those wives hey
let's all go out and I got three tickets
to the the XYZ
um let's all go and you just foot the
bill let's all take let's take them out
let's go do this but that's a great idea
all right last one
hold on you're smiling before you even
ask this I can see this I don't know
what's coming I think this is a good
question that a lot of couples have and
by a lot you mean you and your husband
go ahead
how many times a week should a couple
have sex
yeah 10 11. I'm scared I'm just kidding
uh you're welcome gentlemen you're
welcome
um
man that okay so I get that question a
lot how often should a couple have sex
it's a couple different things number
one
um some people
the barometer for connectivity in the
relationship is sex that is that brings
peace to their body physiologically that
grounds them
um for some people it's Recreation for
some people it is
um it's a way to unplug and it's like
watching Lord of the Rings I can go be
somebody else do something else over
here we can become a different couple
over here because over here I wear a
suit and I go to work and I'm a dork and
I'm a mom I'm a dad over here I can get
off the rail so sex means different
things to different people and there's
different seasons in some Seasons I'm
writing a book and I'm really busy and
other Seasons man things are just
cooking and other Seasons we have a
two-year-old and a five-year-old and
then I'm pregnant so here's the thing
how many times you should you have sex
as many times as both of you can
honestly and fully
um commit to one another to doing it
over the course of one week two weeks
three weeks four weeks
um I think
kind of like weighing yourself uh every
day it's not it's not really a helpful
metric over time a trend is helpful so
if you get to the end of the week and
like we only did it once this week we're
falling apart you're not if you get to
the end of
three months and we've had sex two or
three times and man I really am missing
my wife or I'm really missing my husband
what's going on
that is a trend right let's have that
conversation but
um I think it's what both people agree
on it's just that Kelly most people
agree on it they lie to each other I'm
cool I'm fine or nah nah it's good be
honest about your needs and figure it
out that way is that does that sound
fair yeah I think that's great okay
because I don't think there's a there's
not a numerical answer it's different
for everybody and I actually
um there is like a statistically most
couples have sex this often I'm actually
don't give that out because I every
couple is different and every couple has
diff is in a different season the same
as people are like what um what what
foods should you eat man that's a
that's it depends on what your goals are
and what you're doing it's got so many
factors to it so similar to that
question the key is be honest and
intentional about it
here we go you survived it that was it
that was it
I like jobs those are fun thanks for
setting that up thanks for doing it all
right
we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we are back thanks for joining
us today on the Dr John deloney show
um again if you want to be on the show
reach out to us you can email us at John
deloney.com ask and don't forget to pick
up own your pass change your future
um number one best-selling book uh
it's good I'm proud of it pick it up uh
give it a shot all right um today's song
of the day is from the great Elton John
and the song is Saturday nights all
right for fighting
it's getting late have you seen my mates
ma tell me when the boys get here it's
seven o'clock and I want to rock wanna
get a belly full of beer oh this sounds
like the song Kelly wrote my old man's
drunker than a barrel full of monkeys
and my old lady she don't care my sister
looks cute in her braces and boots I got
a handful of grease in her hair
yeah right
don't give us none of your aggravation
we had it with your discipline Saturday
nights all right for fighting get a
little action in get about as oiled as a
diesel train gonna set this dance a
light cause Saturday night's the night I
like
Saturday night's all right all right all
right we'll see you soon
[Music]